alright so next up we have gentleman I'm
us are gonna tell us about alt or super
resolution for sparse interpolation you
can remeasurement two things the
organizer for this invitation and the
talk will be about spot interpolation in
a relationship with a super resolution
and the pony method anyway that we also
linked with what Monique has presented
before so the this don't work with
Cecilia shot which is now a postdoc at
UC Berkeley and they're number one from
in area and it's based on this guy's
paper here the message of the talk is
that if you study some questions for
some question that used to D about
polynomials they could be interpreted as
a sign measures on appropriate
geometrical objects and for Adam it
known that if you take the imagine use
the convex cone of motion use polynomial
of degree 2 D then the dual which is
understood as a measure linear
functionals is also put the space of
polynomial which are the ^ linear forms
that's an example where you can
interpret a polynomial as a measure and
in fact for example this has been used
in recent work and recovery of a tensor
for example there was nice paper by
hanging shine position stirrer so for
example if you would like to recover the
decomposition of a three tensor in this
case if it is symmetric you can also do
the same thing for modulus polynomial
cubic then you can interpret so this is
your tensor a so you can interpret say
you want to find this decomposition so a
is given and you want to find this
decomposition right and you can
interpret this as a atomic measure okay
on the unit sphere and the idea is from
them and they should be used each
coefficient a a ijk should be viewed as
a moment of a measure on the sphere so
the idea is you would like to recover
from the knowledge of the moment you
would like to recover a measure on the
sphere and that's typically what
supervisor
Joan is doing the theory of
super-resolution they can this and then
there is a nice theory because depending
on whether or not your atoms are
sufficiently separated geometrically
then you can recover exactly your tensor
or your measure by solving an SCP for
example in the univariate case so those
those papers are exactly in this period
and Monique talk and review also as
exactly this approach wire for your for
tensor of CPS Duran want to retrieve a
measure on the abstract sphere from
knowledge of some moments at the end to
do that you minimize the two toleration
norm of your non-mirror that's one way
to see some point numerals related to v
measures so coefficient of that of this
tensor the coefficient should be view as
a moment of some measure this talk is
different but again we will use this
this an imputation of a polynomial as a
measure so here it was passing
depressions or what is it so you have
black box this black box is a non
polynomial okay you know it is a
polynomial but you don't know is the
coefficient of this polynomial and the
only thing you can do is just do
evaluations okay and the problem is that
how could you retrieve especially if you
know that piece parts has very few
coefficients how could you retrieve P
from Malaysia only of a few evaluations
okay and in this case you have a lot of
freedom because you can choose the
points where you evaluate your
polynomial so you put in n 3z k and then
the output is the evaluation of pH DK
and from this knowledge you would like
to retrieve P and the message of the
talk is that in this case P can be
considered the sign boiled measure
atomic under n-torus we will see how it
works okay and again the game would be
to retrieve your measure from knowledge
from moments we will see that these are
moments of this mirror
SP is parts polynomial then the idea
that you need few evaluation to recover
your black box putting on your P and no
so what is yeah let's say there's a
well-known method for you for doing this
which is called prony method which is
very old method and it was usually
designed for recovering not to make
measure so suppose you have a function H
of fix which is given like this so you
have a some finitely many Exponential's
with white WI so they are known are WI
and have I and you want to retrieve the
WI and fi given some evaluation H of fix
at some points okay the idea of point is
very simple you generate first point on
we also put you put the e of fi as roots
of some univariate polynomial we define
this polynomial okay this problem you'll
have some unknown coefficient QJ because
you don't know of course guys and the
thing is that this polynomial the vector
of question of this problem you're
satisfying our creation where the blue
data are they are coming from the
evaluation of H of X we evaluate H of X
at some points to give you some anchor
matrix and H of Q satisfies this linear
system HQ ik of this so you evaluate
your age at some points you solve for
this linear system that give you Q and
then from the Q's and recover the WI
this is a purely algebraic method to
recover univariate polynomial also for
and you reform measure but you can do it
for sparse in interpolation also and
Thomas to recover the unknown degree are
and premiere from to our evaluations
well I passed this but the way to do it
for this was for measure but you can
wait for polynomial interpolation for
the frame of interpolation so you're
putting on your pin down is unknown
which coefficient P i okay then you
again the same thing you fix X 0 so you
look at this polynomial now you fix X 0
you look at this polynomial with unknown
coefficients and you will satisfy again
an inner system of equations where the
blue are coming from for just some
evaluations so evaluate at some points
we've used this matrix H and this sima
vector Sigma and then you solve for this
in our system it will give you the queue
and from the Q then you retrieve also
the solid you give the coefficient like
this and there is an extension to the
multivariate case which are done by many
people but in particular by NAMM well
and what what why people don't use this
for I mean it's not a systematic method
which is used in this case because it is
the claim is that this method is not
very robust to noise if your data if
your evaluations are noisy then you
cannot recover your poem you're very
nicely we will have some propagation
favored and ponies not considered to be
a stable method so what would be another
method to recover your pre-nominal would
be what i call here the naive compressed
sensing so your point number is given
like this so you don't know the
coefficients you assume you have a bound
on the degree and the knife LP would be
the following so you evaluate your point
nominal at some points arbitrary they
give you bi that you know this bi and
then you say okay I look for this vector
of coefficients of my polynomial so this
is a valuation at the point Z I ok the
QR the unknown and then you minimize the
l1 norm so be a very naive way to do it
okay
because it's not that if you minimize
the l1 norm you tend to recover spot
solution to your in our equations okay
and why is it naive because
there is a well-known theory of
cooperate sensing to recover an optimal
solution from this LP but to guarantee
that you recover your the the solution
that you are looking for
you need some assumption on the a to
have a guarantee that you recover your Q
from this linear system of equation when
you minimize zl1 known and this is
called a restricted isometry property so
the j is very simple so your Q is a very
large size vector and by minimizing the
l1 norm which is positive inducing you
I'm at finding a solution of your
problem will be sparse here so this LP
will have a sparse polynomial but you
know is no guarantee that you recover
your polynomial okay and this l1 norm is
just a subsidiary for this sort of norm
of counting the number of distinct
elements okay and the compressing in
theory I said that you would recover
exactly your polynomial if your matrix a
at this particular isometric isometric
property sufficient conditions don't
necessary but to be sure that you
recover your nominal if a satisfy this
property indeed you recover your
polynomial okay
but for sparse polynomial interpolation
it does not satisfy in our setting this
neighbors that's why I call it naive LP
because in this case the matrix a for
for if you try to recover your
polynomial by solving this the matrix a
does not satisfy the reciept isometry
property okay so you can see try it work
sometimes but you have no guarantee
so what is super-resolution that's
another method to do it consider for an
interest in the complex en okay and
suppose you are given a mirror so this
is a basic idea bit between behind the
super-resolution suppose you have an
atomic measure so you have atoms G K on
the torus and weights not necessarily
positive it could be a sign measure so
you have a measure unknown you know it
is atomic and very sparse with a few
atoms and you know only some moments of
this measure examine you know the m
alpha okay
and the goal again is to recover your
measure from knowledge of a few m alpha
okay
can you recover from a few scalar m
alpha can you recover the theta K and G
K versus old super-resolution urea said
that indeed nu nu star is a unique
optimal solution of this infinite
dimensional LP so you try now you
optimize the verse of an LP over the set
of measures on the torus your
constraints say that you look for a
measure mu that are satisfied the MIMO
the moment constraints okay and you
minimize total variations total
variation should be seen as the L 1 norm
in the case of a vector okay and
super-resolution Theory say the
following if you have enough
measurements moments here and if the
point the atoms of your measure are
sufficiently separated on the torus then
you can this first of all this L
anything dimensional P has a unique
solution which is exactly the measure
you are looking for and in the case in
the univariate case you can recover your
measure exactly by solving a single SDP
this is a famous paper back and s and
fan on the veranda okay and there was
some extension to the multivariate case
so what I claiming that the this tensor
recovery program we have seen at the
beginning
oh sorry
I cannot retreat
how did you come back
could you back for flights okay thank
you very much
remember our tensor recovery program at
the beginning was exactly
super-resolution you are given you are
looking for a measure mu not on the
torus moments fear in this case given
some coefficient of your tensor but the
position of your tensor should be view
as moments of this measure that you look
for so given the moments of your measure
on the sphere you try to recover your
tensor and you minimize the one norm
okay so that was this society behind the
super resolution so we have seen pony
methods the naive compress and single P
approach to recover your spouse
polynomial and the super resolution are
three methods now we go back to the spot
interpolation because of you have seen
this for just recovering a measure and
yeah the central idea is very simple
here just one slide is to interpret
polynomial P as a sine measure how you
do that so you fix a point 0 and n torus
fix the 0 once poorer and let P you and
not be you're a non polynomial then
suppose we evaluate P at the power beta
of 0 what is it so it's exactly equal to
Sigma of P alpha D 0 beta to the power
alpha right my definition of P but you
can the the idea that you can interplay
you can put the alpha instead of the
beta and vice versa so it's equal to P
of alpha 0 alpha to beta then you can
see if you see this as a jihad at the
point Z 0 alpha this is just evaluation
of the moment beta of this Dirac
okay so when you evaluate in other words
when you evaluate the polynomial P at
the power beta of this point D 0 then
you are just about ready
the moment beta of this atomic measure
and this atomic measure is what the
coefficient is the weight is just the
coefficient alpha of your polynomial and
the Atem
okay it's just the Dirac at the point
GGO to the power alpha the message is
very simple evaluating P at the 0 beta
is just computing the beta moment of
this manner so while back to
super-resolution because given an
arbitrary fixity you know on the tour
you fix the 0 then every polynomial P
can be viewed on the sine boil measure
on the torus okay with finance report
which are just the atoms eeo to the
power alpha or the coefficient are
different from zero and weights P alpha
and the evaluation of P at the point is
your beta just a moment limiter of this
measure and if you won't recover a space
for new LP from few evaluation pxk this
is exactly equivalent to recovering a
measure mu we space report on the torus
from few moments okay so you have your
moment beta which of the evaluation at
the power bit of Z 0 and you want to
retrieve your measure on the N torres
from the knowledge of these moments but
it's exactly super what super-resolution
is doing right so now you just import
the tools from super resolution to say
that under some condition there is a
nice way to recover your unknown point
it would be the unique solution of
certain problem so your space polynomial
would be the unique solution of this
infant dimensional LP on the space of
measures so you look for a measure muon
the torus you have some evaluations we
have view as moments of this measure and
you minimize the total variation so and
the message that if the atoms are
sufficiently separated on the torus and
you have enough measurements I mean in
that evaluation then you the open on
your is exactly your unique solution
of this problem okay done if you will be
a polynomial in one variable you can so
you can recover your point nominal in
just solving a single ACP so how do you
solve this engine dimensional LP so you
have a measure of MU which is a sine
measure so you say okay I consider this
measure R to be the difference of the
difference of two positive measure five
percent five miners so you have the
moment condition here and the total
variation is just mass of the two
measure of Phi plus and five minutes
when the audit joints and you solve this
SDP by using the moment approach right
let me solve this SDP equation by
considering a finite you truncate the
arm so you have the fixed moment up to
order D but you go to either moment
which are unknown and then this video to
Pete's mattress moment the moment matrix
of this measure and non measure Cyprus
and five - or just to appease mattress
which also supposed to be positive
semi-definite and you solve this SDP and
if dimension reads one and two you are
guaranteed to find the exact solution
infinitely many steps and in general
only simple tickly and in fact in
practice convergence is finite and
extraction procedure can be done
okay now there is an additional thing
which is a relatively interesting in the
fact that for the interpolation problem
it's a bit different from super
resolution in the sense that it's it's
even more it's a special case of super
resolution in the size that you have the
choice of truth you have the choice of
your initial point Z here on the torus
and for example you can choose this
point you take n large enough and if you
take n large enough you can ask you you
assume that your atoms are just on a
grid on your torus on a fixed grid in
this case when you do that if we end
sufficiently large you know that the
atoms will be on this green and this is
a particular case of super resolution
which is called discrete super
resolution and then there is a way of in
this case you have an exact analog of
this super resolution problem as an LP
with total variation norm which is the
compression sing approach so in this
case if you fix the zero like I said
then your super resolution problem
becomes an LP okay I mean you can solve
it as an LP with minimum minimizing the
L 1 norm and you are by since it is
completely equivalent to the super
resolution you have the guarantee I can
test your M that your problem your P
will be the unique solution you need to
put in repeat that you look for is a
unique version of this LP even if the
matrix a does not satisfy the elastic
isometric property in this case so if
you have enough measurements okay this
LP which is not too naive one because
you don't do the evaluation arbitrarily
you do it on the torus by doing this
this is exactly equivalent to super
resolution and theory to set that in
this case there is a unique solution to
your problem and it is also the unique
solution of this LP ok so this provides
a nice example where you have an exact
recovery which is possible by solving an
LP even if the matrix a does not satisfy
the restricted isometric property
just an example to show you a how it
works first of all in the univariate
case for to start with
suppose you have a point on your for
example the offer one variable of a
degree 80 with 3 atoms at the 80s 25 and
20 as DVD 80 with all these free
monomials so you fit for example doubt
to approach is that you fix the 0 to be
this one and like I said in the
beginning and you can solve also when LP
so you want to find a measure on until
the torus with three atoms out of
potentially 101 for example and in fact
you recover your reservist for
evaluations only and with only two pitch
matrices of size 4x4 for example on the
torus your three atoms are the blue out
a positive one to positive weights and
one negative way so you blew out the
positive weights and go rather than a
negative one okay and then this is your
atomic measure on the torus on the dual
which is I didn't talk about the war but
the war is just looking for a polynomial
which is between minus 1 and 1 which is
bounded between minus 1 and 1 and you
will touch one the blue points and minus
1 at the red point
this is a dual of the ACP ok this is
when I when I fix the hero like this but
you can also fix the 0 to be a rational
on the torus and then this case it's
much more interesting in a sense because
it for example with the choice the
points are much more separated and your
numerically it's even easier because
then you have the support is more
separated right
and then for example we have a tried
that on a civil several example of exam
here we have you know eight three
variables ten variables okay and we have
compared the three methods is always a
rigorous LP okay and super resolution so
you see we know that we find the exact
solution in this case and if this is a
number of measurements for which we
cover your exact the number of
evaluation needed to recover your exact
polynomial by the LP of super-resolution
it's very comparable is about brownie or
super resolution this is with the exact
no noise in the data okay and if you
have if you corrupt now your data by
noise with some noise even relatively
with I value for exam here the noise was
uniformly distributed in this interval
so it's quite a large error in
evaluation and then you so you find you
saw your rigorous LP or your super
resolution or prony you get something
and you look at the error you commit you
have with the original polynomial that
you had in your black box and you see
that in indeed Ronnie is not that
sensitive to error okay
and it's quite comparable to super
evolution and so for example in the
paper by Candice it is claimed that the
algebraic method like phony are not
rubbish to noise and that's what we
didn't find for those examples this was
funny was quite robust I mean it was
we have to know that not necessarily
because you make you man you make your
matrix you're in a sort of thinking
matrix that grows or you couldn't have a
bound on the degree also if you want
which super I'll show you don't need a
bomb the HDPE is the separation
aggression you don't need to know the
degree for the LP you know to note you
need to know the degree lower bound on
the degree and for prolly I think you
can you can propagate your uncle matrix
you don't know the size in advance and
you look just for candor of some anchor
matrix what we observe is that in fact
with the noise because we have some
solace key decomposition to do at some
moment and what we are starting our
experiment is that probably what people
do is they do a very small threshold on
the eigen values to declare their eigen
value is zero but if you need if you let
this threshold to be quite large that we
find almost exactly the same robustness
at the super resolution which is a bit
surprising but you're gonna optimize
and those you have to extract you have
to basically do a pony on your exactly
so it getaway the super resolution kind
of makes it more regular but
in fact when I almost finished my talk
and so the in fact you can see super
resolution at the end but what is super
torsion is doing you solve an SDP and
when some series ranked condition
satisfied you stop but you don't you
still will not have your polynomial you
seem to have to extract your point on
your from your solution of your ACP and
the last step this step of extraction is
exactly a pro nematode actually so you
have your moment matrix of the to
measure of 5 + + 5 - and from this you
extract your non polynomial but this
extraction procedure is exactly a pony
method actually so you could see super
resolution as a sort of a filter you
first do an optimization step and then
you do a sort of perimeter to extract
was pony method is just doing extraction
directly without doing any any
optimization but solving roots of a of
polynomials in one variable no better
so extraction of atomic exactly a pony
image was actually and you could see
that the optimization step in your semi
definite programming problem is exacting
as a filter to attenuate the effect of
noise action and there you go LP
compression Seng behaves quite well even
even with noise was quite satisfactory
but the set up to to set up your LP is
much more time-consuming so this stall
was about to say that is for some
problems concerning polynomials if you
if you have some special glasses you can
see that as a as a measure and you have
an inverse problem of recovering a
measure from some data for example in
rank
the tensor problem is that your data are
the coefficient of your tensor okay and
those coefficients are seen as moments
of some measure on the sphere and from
the knowledge of this coefficient you
want to recover your measure on the
sphere you have Tom's on this year and
that give you the decomposition force
passing the operation it's a basically
almost the same story now your
coefficient are not known your nominal
is unknown okay but you want to recover
it you see you say that it is a sine
measure on the torus and you have access
to some evaluation and the evaluations
so you evaluate your point on your at
some points on the torus that give you
some data and this data is exactly the
moments of an unknown measure on the
torus and again the game is given some
moments on the torus or some measure on
the Tori
given some moments of the measure on the
torus sorry you want to recover the
measure from knowledge of this moment
and then you minimize in both case you
minimize the total variation of your
mirror is on the sphere for the tensor
or on the torus for this spacing
operation what was the message of the
[Applause]
we cameras LP you need to set up the LP
with bound bound on the degree of your
polynomial yes that's why is DP doesn't
need that that's the difference between
the two no the fact the sparsity appears
in the fact that you will need few
evaluation to recover it if your
premiere would not be sparse you will
need a lotta value of you know a lot of
measurements moments or evaluations to
recover it well for us passer
interpolation you know that you are
exactly if you if you if you know album
degree you know bound on the evaluations
a number of evaluations that would be
enormous
doulas SDP department that if you if if
you don't know exactly you feel enough
in the information on your sparsity you
you end up with something at the end
okay but guaranteed theory of
super-resolution guarantee you that it
is your real object that you are looking
for provide that you have some
information that you don't have so you
have something and you leave that to in
fact and practice you would have to
check if it is a good one but that's
that's the only way you do if you don't
want to do all the evaluations
[Applause]